the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu
hi welcome back i am dr. bugged alpha
delish let's solve some more
biochemistry problems today we're going
to be talking about problem 3 a problem
set 10 now this is a problem about the
spontaneity of gluconeogenesis as you
guys have already learned
gluconeogenesis is the process by which
non-sugar precursors are used to produce
glucose this problem should help you
think of the following conundrum in a
Cell when we have glucose we can make
energy by doing glycolysis but at the
same time the cell can take for example
the endpoints of glycolysis such as
pyruvate or even further metabolites
like amino acids and use the pathway in
Reverse to make glucose now if one
process is spontaneous in terms of time
thermodynamics then how could we run the
reaction in Reverse so here we're going
to be looking at a couple of steps of
gluconeogenesis that are the exact
reverse of the reactions that you've
seen already in glycolysis and then in
the end we're going to be talking about
the whole pathway level and make some
comments on the spontaneity of both
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis
part a of the problem deals with the
aldolase reaction namely going from
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate to
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate and by haider
acetone phosphate now in gluconeogenesis
will be going in reverse starting with
the Hydra acetone phosphate and
glyceraldehyde 3-phosphate to regenerate
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate let's take a
look at the reaction this is the hydro
acetone phosphate this is
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate or gap and
these two come together in the aldolase
reaction to form fructose 1 6
bisphosphate or f 16 BP now the part 1
of the question asked us to write down
the detailed mechanism for this reaction
running in reverse so as you guys know
aldolase specifically the class 1 alder
lazes use an active site lysine residue
to to covalently bind the substrate
during the course of the reaction so
this reaction will proceed by dihydrogen
phosphate binding to the exercise lysine
of the aldolase here we have the
dihydrogen phosphate and the lysine in
the active site so as the first step of
the mechanism the lysine is going to
react with the carbonyl group in that
hydrostan phosphate to form a ship space
or an e mean as you can imagine the
reaction is going to be catalyzed by the
general base which is going to remove
one of the protons from the lysine which
then becomes a good nucleophile and can
attack the carbonyl which can then will
be protonated by a general acid so this
way you obtain an intermediate as shown
here which can then lose the water
molecule to form the shift base once
again we need a base that will
take this proton and then the water will
need another acid molecule to leave so
what we have formed here this is the
protonated shift base or what we call an
amine IAM ion and if you look at edit
from the point of view of where we
started from which was a carbonyl group
this is a version of an activated
carbonyl carbon yo Derwood it's now
poised to do chemistry once again this
is this is the iminium ion now as we
talked in the carbonyl video aminium
ions are activated carbonyls that can
now undergo some of the carbonyl
reactions which more ease for example
this one is going to do an inhalation so
we have highlighted here the alpha
hydrogen next to the carbonyl group so
we were going to form the you know by
removing this hydrogen and the carbonyl
with this positive charge on the
nitrogen so that a very good electron
sink so what we're forming here is a an
amine that's bound to a double bond this
we're going to call and in amin now this
is the reactive version of the
dihydrogen phosphate now it's poised to
react with the other partner in the
reaction gap glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate
which we've shown here now gap is going
to be the carbonyl component of this
aldol reaction while the eno mean from
the dihydrogen phosphate is going to be
the the enoli component right so the
enol is going to be a very good
nucleophile and it's going to attack the
carbonyl the reaction is once again
initiated by this amine group the
electrons move here then this attacks
the carbonyl and we can protonate it
with a general acid
so what we obtain here it's now a
molecule that has from two portions of
three it's going to have six carbons and
if you look closely this is really the
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate bound to the
active site of the enzyme as a shift
space okay so now all that needs to
happen now is to hydrolyze the ship
space and release ours are fructose 1 6
bisphosphate product so we're going to
need one water molecule it's going to be
activated by a general base then it's
going to attack this amine and the
electrons will move to the nitrogen we
get to this step and here we need step
in catalysis to regenerate the enzyme to
its free lysine form and then release
the fructose 1 6 bisphosphate product of
the reaction so once again we started
with dihydrogen phosphate and gap and
you use this covalent catalysis where
the substrate were bound in the active
site of the enzyme to form our product
fructose 1 6 bisphosphate now this as we
discussed in the carbonyl chemistry just
an example of direct aldol reaction and
as the name of the enzyme suggests
aldolase this is the reaction going in
the gluconeogenic mold
and part b of the question we're going
to look in another important reaction
that can run both ways in glycolysis and
gluconeogenesis that will be
specifically going from
glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate or gap to 13
bits phosphoglycerate this is the
reaction catalyzed by gap dehydrogenase
here is a representation of the reaction
we have glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate that
is converted by gap th to the 13 bits
forceful glyceride now in the glycolysis
step we know we need one nad equivalent
and one phosphate inorganic phosphate to
go into the enzyme to be able to oxidize
our aldehyde to an sitting and hydride
in 13 bits phosphoglycerate now in a
gluconeogenesis we're going to be going
from right to left we're starting with
13 bits phosphoglycerate we're going to
need nadh and we're going to generate
gap and inorganic phosphate now let's
take a closer look at the mechanism of
this reaction as it would run in
gluconeogenesis here we have a
representation of the active side of the
gap th where we highlighted the Sistine
group SH right and we also have in
general base in the exercise we're going
to call it be and here is our starting
material 13 / phosphoglycerate now if
you remember how gap the edge works in
the direct reaction in the glycolysis
we're going to have to form a covalent
intermediate in which the substrate is
going to bind to the enzyme that's going
to form a a diode ester with that tile
group of the Sistine so this is what's
going to happen here so the base in the
active side actually is going to assist
deprotonation of the Sistine then the
tile now it's activated and it can
attack the first 100 of the 13 [ __ ]
phosphoglycerate and in the first step
is just going to form a tetrahedral
intermediate there you have it now we
have a negative charge on
on the oxygen and we spelled out the
phosphate with all the atoms here all
right as you know these tetrahedral
intermediate is not going to fall apart
releasing like the most the best leaving
group in this case is going to be the
inorganic phosphate select the electrons
come down is going to be transferred
onto the phosphate and presumably
protonated we can alright so after the
phosphate is released now we we have
flown finally the tile ester of our
substrate in the active side of gap th
as you remember this is a redox
reactions involve the cofactor nad in
this case running the reaction from
right to left we're going to use NADH to
reduce the base phosphoglycerate to the
aldehyde group so here is our
representation of the NADH as you
remember one of these hydrogen's
together with its electron pair it's
going to be donated as a hydride or h-
all right so this the reaction proceeds
by rearranging the electrons on the
pyridine ring of nad and the h minus is
going to be the nucleophile that's
attacking now but I Lester once again
I'm going to be forming a tetrahedral
intermediate which is shown here now
this hydride here is the one that came
from nadh and in the process the NADH
cofactor is converted to NAD+ alright so
now we can see we're just one step away
this is now a like a hemiacetal like
molecule so it's one step away from
forming glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate all
we need to do is release the enzyme in
its original confirmation so the
electrons will flow now to reform the
carbonyl while the sulfur is going to
get its electrons from the base and
and this regenerates the enzyme as we
had it in the beginning and we're
releasing gap the product of the
reaction so with this mechanistic
insight we have actually addressed how
the gap th reaction runs in the
gluconeogenic mode from 13 bits
phosphoglycerate to gap now part a of
the problem also asked us to look up the
free energy value for the aldolase
reaction that is the Delta G naught
prime now if you're going to look in
your favorite chemistry textbook or I
have here the fold and vote third
edition the book that we use in in this
course now you're going to find in on
page 511 you're going to see a table
with all the free energies of glycolysis
reactions and for the aldolase tab
you're going to see that it's a positive
free energy that is the reaction
spontaneous in the reverse in the
gluconeogenic direction so now that that
may be a little surprising but keep in
mind that the reactions in these
pathways are more often than not
governed by mass action that is if we
have an excess of the starting materials
the reaction will proceed towards the
product while if you have an excess of
the products the reaction will proceed
backwards towards the starting materials
so both the aldolase reaction and the
gap dehydrogenase reactions are very
susceptible to this mass action so they
will be controlled the direction the
spontaneity of this reaction will be
controlled by which of the starting
materials or products are in excess
Part C of this problem asked us to
evaluate the spontaneity of
gluconeogenesis at the level of the
whole pathway now we know glycolysis is
a spontaneous process not only it it
occurs from goes from glucose to
pyruvate but it also it generates some
high-energy intermediates like ATP in
the process I will get two molecules of
ATP per glucose now if we want to go
backwards from pyruvate to glucose in a
gluconeogenesis pathway can this process
be spontaneous first let's look at
glycolysis here is a schematic of
glycolysis we're starting here from
glucose and we're going to need a couple
of molecules of ATP to activate it to
get to fructose 1 6 bisphosphate and
from there on we're going to generate
actually two molecules of ATP at this
step and then two molecules of ATP at
the final part of the kinase step and of
course we're also going to need an nad
plus going to NADH here at the gap step
well there's going to be two of these
NAD+ needed to oxidize gap to 1 through
peaceful for glycerin all right and as
we just said even though we have some
energy costs in early on we're actually
generating more ATP by the time we reach
pyruvate so the pathway is in fact
spontaneous now what about
gluconeogenesis in google neurogenesis
we're starting with pyruvate and we want
to go back to glucose now if we were to
reverse exactly every single step in
glycolysis that price password is not
going to be spontaneous so that for
gluconeogenesis uses these alternate
pathways and couple of the steps in
order to make the process spontaneous
for example going from pyruvate to
phosphoenolpyruvate in gluconeogenesis
is not a reverse of the fast part of it
kinase reaction and rather occur since
two steps the first step we take part of
it and convert it to oxaloacetate using
pyruvate carboxylase
is going to going to need a molecule of
co2 right oxaloacetate has four carbons
and it's also going to need energy so
we're going to need a molecule of ATP
going to adp now oxaloacetate then can
now be processed inside the mitochondria
or it can be taken out of the
mitochondria into the cytosol and let's
say that's the course of the reaction
where it's going to find an enzyme
called PP carboxykinase or Pepsi k that
can take off cell acetate to PP this
enzyme once again requires energy this
time the form of GTP goes to gdp and
here we're going to lose that carboxyl
group that we added on earlier now while
this might seem like a sort of a
cumbersome way to reverse one reaction
this allows both the part of it kinase
reaction and going from pyruvate going
back to PP to be controlled in different
ways and therefore allow both of these
processes to happen spontaneously the
rest of gluconeogenesis will have
exactly the reverse of these steps in
glycolysis for example PP going to two
phosphoglycerate the Fox will get her
going to 3-phosphoglycerate
3-phosphoglycerate going to 13 bits
phosphoglycerate here since in
glycolysis which generated ATP here
we're going to need the ATP to come in
and go to adp in order to accomplish the
step in gluconeogenesis 13 bits 44
glyceride going to gap this is the step
we'll just discussed in part two of the
problem as we said we're going to need
NADH going to NAD+ then gap and DHAP
going to fructose 1 6 bisphosphate this
is the step we discussed in part a of
this problem the reverse of the aldolase
reaction no going from fructose 1 6 bit
faster
to glucose we're not going to do these
kinase reactions in Reverse where would
be generating ATP and therefore there
would be not spontaneous in the reverse
direction but rather we're going to use
alternate enzymes called phosphatases
where we lose the phosphate without
regenerating and ATP molecules so
therefore by using these these two
tricks we can go back to glucose without
regenerating its ATP molecules and
therefore the pathway can be spontaneous
now the bottom line here is that both
glycolysis and gluconeogenesis are
spontaneous but gluconeogenesis uses
most but not all of the glycolysis steps
to run in reverse and while glycolysis
generates energy we'd get a net of two
molecules of ATP per molecule of glucose
used gluconeogenesis as you guys seen
I've seen here actually uses energy to
run if spontaneously that is we need ATP
molecules now if you look at our diagram
we need ATP molecules to convert
pyruvate to phosphoenolpyruvate actually
two of them and then we're going to need
more ATP here to form 13 bits
phosphoglycerate in addition to the
redox like NADH cofactor to run the gap
dehydrogenase reaction in Reverse so
given these considerations
gluconeogenesis is in fact spontaneous
but it's going to cost us several ATP
equivalents while glycolysis are
spontaneous and generate ATP well that
solves problem 3 or problems at 10 here
I hope you've got a better understanding
of why both glycolysis and
gluconeogenesis are both spontaneous
pathways inside the cell thank you